[Musique]
nouvelle édition du 7 8 ce politique sur
tv 78 merci de nous rejoindre voici les
principaux titres un nouveau maire pour
bois d'arcy jean-philippe lui succède à
philippe benassaya devenus députés en
septembre il est l'invité de cette
édition nous reviendrons sur les enjeux
de ce mandat mais aussi sur la gestion
de la crise sanitaire actuelle par ses
services
au chesnay rocancourt 76 voix séparaient
les deux candidats aux municipales en
mars dernier en poste depuis 1989
philippe brillault n'a pas voulu
accepter sa défaite son recours devant
le tribunal administratif a été payant
le scrutin vient tout juste d'être
invalidées en raison d'irrégularités et
puis quelle date
quelle organisation pour les prochaines
élections régionales et départementales
le consensus semble se faire autour de
juin 2021 le vote par correspondance lui
fait débat
bonsoir jean philippe plus bonsoir vous
êtes le nouveau maire de bois d'arcy
depuis le 7 novembre dernier commune de
15000 habitants bienvenue en plateau
bien s'il avait 36 ans vous étiez depuis
2014 maire-adjoint d'abord à la culture
et au développement économique en 2020
en charge des finances de la réussite
éducative
cela a été de courte durée pour ce
deuxième poste d'adjoint puisque
maintenant vous êtes donc le nouveau
maire vous avez aussi connu à
l'opposition a uniquement sur le mandat
de 2008 finalement quand on regarde
votre carrière politique elle a été
assez rapide
vous aviez un plan de carrière aussi
rapide non mais je ne le conçois pas la
petite commune carrière d'ailleurs c'est
le plan de carrière est un peu exagéré
mais mais c'est vrai que voilà il ya des
histoires qui se crée notamment que
notre député actuel philippe benassaya
qui j'ai rencontré il ya maintenant que
depuis 10 ans grec est à l'origine de
votre engagement c'est là aussi où je
voulais en venir vous avez commencé la
politique avec nous ouais c'est ça je me
suis engagé à 24 ans en fait c'est dans
le cadre des élections présidentielle et
législatives de 2007
et très vite j'ai rencontré philippe à
bois d'arcy pour la campagne de 2008 et
on a continué ensemble ce chemin en
effet d'abord dans l'opposition
malheureusement en 2008 mais c'est
formateur est très intéressant de vivre
aussi un mandat dans l'opposition j'ai
fait deux ans et puis après depuis
surtout la joie de la victoire en 2014
et donc ce parcours qu'on fait ensemble
finalement et cette continuité va
continuer à travers ce nouveau pas en me
laissant la place de maires élus lors du
dernier conseil municipal avec les voix
de l'équipe williams l'activité
politique prend de plus en plus de temps
pour vous mais né au mans vous gardez
votre activité professionnelle
oui pour l'instant je vais équilibré les
deux évidemment ça évidemment je suis au
service des artisiens donc j'ai passé
beaucoup plus de temps aux mairies mais
pour l'instant pour regarder aussi ce
lien avec l'activité professionnelle qui
est important je vais continuer
équilibré tous à devenir intelligente
alors on le disait votre carrière
politique est liée à celle de philippe
benassaya l'ancien maire qui a donc
démissionné en raison de la loi de non
cumul des mandats il est aujourd'hui
député et puis il est aussi conseiller
départemental
on va l'écouter il était présent
forcément au dernier conseil municipal
lors de votre élection il était
forcément satisfait c'est une zone
il consacre aussi la continuité des
projets la continuité l'équipe
ce que j'ai mis en marche ce que j'ai
mis en projet donc voilà je suis à la
fois heureux quand jean philippe heureux
pour l'équipe est rassuré parce que tout
va continuer comme avant et je serai
bien sûr là pour continuer à veiller à
la bonne application du programme
votre action va s'inscrire dans la
continuité mais évidemment on a été élu
sur une liste où il était tête de liste
en mars dernier les arcisienne nous ont
fait confiance sur un projet et ça
serait incompréhensible d'arrêter ce
projet de faire totalement des choses
totalement différentes
donc évidemment les projets vont se
faire il ya une totale continuité il
sera d'ailleurs là à nos côtés est à mes
côtés assez régulièrement
très régulièrement pour pouvoir réussir
ces projets qui sont bien à 50 il a des
très beaux on va en parler mais qui sont
très prenant et très très ambitieux et
donc il faut qu'on y arrive à les faire
et donc l'aide d'un député et conseiller
départemental pour y arriver est plus
qu'importante
mais au moins il ya peut-être des
projets qui vous tiennent plus à coeur
aussi vous allez tout de même mettre
votre pâte j'imagine
au cours de ce mandat quel est le projet
prioritaire pour cela il n'a pas qu'un
il y en a plusieurs années 50 il est
sale et 50 il a deux trois qui sont
vraiment très important il y en a un qui
me tient très à coeur
chez un enfant de boire sinon j'ai
grandi et j'ai grandi à bercy et il ya
le centre de loisirs la colombe qu'on va
commencer à reconstruire
c'est un projet très beau projet
ambitieux pour accueillir 250 enfants
dont classe s'est lancé et on va on va
j'espère réussir à le boucler assez
rapidement mais on a aussi la
reconstruction du marché on le voit on
va parler avec la crise sanitaire mais
les artisiens et les français de manière
géniale reviennent de plus en plus au
local et au commerce de proximité donc
on a besoin d'avoir un marché plus
fonctionnel et plus adaptée mais aussi
on a les lisières de forêt qui est un
très beau projet de 18 hectares
d'espacés verts on va mettre des spas
tir à l'arc des pistes de pétanque mais
aussi d'un parcours de sécurité routière
progrès pour les enfants donc tout ça
avec toujours évidemment
d'accompagnement des seniors une
modification du pnud j'y tiens parce que
c'est
on a vraiment une ambition de réduire
encore les auteurs et d'accroître la
part des espaces verts dans la ville
tout ça c'est c'est la continuité
évidemment mais des très beaux projets
pour exercer dans des projets qui
peuvent se maintenir malgré le contexte
est
les difficultés financières qui vont en
découler il faut il le faut on peut pas
s'arrêter en chemin l'année 2020 aurait
été très compliqué financièrement
parlant
l'impact du coc vite sur les finances de
la ville aura été assez fort une très
fort entre les recettes qui ne sont plus
là et les dépenses exceptionnelles mais
on arrive à obtenir des subventions et
d'autres routes c'est de trouver
d'autres subventions complémentaires et
faire des économies sur les postes où on
peut essayer de faire des économies pour
financer tous ces projets pour y arriver
parce qu'avant la crise les élus
s'inquiétaient déjà de la baisse des
dotations de l'état avec les
suppressions de taxes d'habitation
notamment
oui il ya la suppression des taxes
habitation qui doit être compensée on
attend le mécanisme effectif il ya la
dotation globale de fonctionnement aussi
qu' étant en baisse relative depuis
depuis forte les années air et les
dernières années est relatif depuis
depuis deux ans
clairement l'état nous aide pas on dit
ce point de vue là c'est à nous de faire
le job est de trouver des économies et
de trouver des financements intelligent
pour pouvoir financer les beaux projets
communs alors aujourd'hui être maire
c'est aussi faire face à cette crise
sanitaire les économies qu'on vient de
l'évoquer dans votre ville les services
sont mobilisés pour aider les plus les
plus âgées peut-être on pourrait aussi
parler des commerces on va lire des
commerces de proximité mais déjà sur
tout l'aspect social solidarité comment
la mairie s'organise au service organise
les services sont ouverts à la grande
différence du confinement précédent
alors on avait mis un numéro pour les
auscitains pouvaient appeler et avoir
leur réponse aujourd'hui les services
municipaux sont ouverts et évidemment il
ya énormément de personnes et notamment
des seniors qui sont isolées donc on est
au contact des des seniors on les
accompagne on essaie de faire des petits
événements pour les aider au quotidien
on comprend des nouvelles on échange
avec eux on les fait on on les fait
participer des événements alors en ligne
c'est plus compliqué mais on est
vraiment la proximité des seniors mais
même finalement les services ont un
travail incroyable
enfin trouvé incroyable quand on voit la
rentrée scolaire et on voit comment ça
s'est passé avec ce protocole qui est
arrivé encore une fois après s'être très
difficile je sais mais au tout dernier
moment il faut adapter le nettoyage de
désinfection
moi je les remercie pour tout travail
qui est fait parce que c'est un vrai
gros travail qui permet de garder ce
lien avec les incidents dd on a trouvé
on est mis à disposition des masques
pour les plus jeunes qui et les
élémentaires qui n'avaient pas de matchs
jusqu'ici
la bonne nouvelle c'est finalement tous
les parents quasiment tous les parents
on avait donné à leurs enfants
mais il y avait ce qu'il fallait et on a
essayé de répondre présent et on a
répondu présent pour accompagner les
artisiens et notamment les seniors qui
souvent isolées elles encore plus isolé
malheureusement on est au contact avec
la ce et régulièrement il ya des mères
qui ont pris la parole qui ont pris des
arrêtés aussi pour aller à l'encontre en
quelque sorte de ce qui avait été décidé
par le gouvernement sur l'ouverture des
petits commerces
ça a été votre cas non on n'a pas pris
d'arrêté on a soutenu la démarche de
l'amifa relation des maires d'île de
france pour pousser pour une ouverture
des commerces de proximité qui sont dits
non essentiel lorsque en fait qui sont
pour eux c'est essentiel d'ouvrir avec
des protocoles sanitaires assez fort il
n'y a pas de raison qu'un commerce de
proximité dit non essentiels ne puisse
pas ouvrir avec des délimitations de
personne dans le magasin on le voit on
le fait dans les boulangeries dans les
boucheries pas de raison que ça puisse
pas se faire on est à une période
charnière pour ces personnes là pour ces
commerçants là il faut qu'on les aide
on les a de nous on ne l'a plus pour
ceux qui sont ouverts en click and
collect ont les mains relations aussi
avec la région qui les accompagnent pour
essayer de passer au click and collect
mais c'est pas suffisant il faut que
j'espère que l'état va leur laisser
cette marge de manoeuvre et ouvrir
prochainement pour pouvoir passer ce
mois de décembre qui est primordial pour
pour pour les commerçants il ya déjà des
commerçants des responsables de petits
commerces qui sont venus vous voir pour
vous dire là je vais faire mais de toute
façon pour l'instant c'est le
confinement moi j'ai fermé pour
l'instant mais de toute façon je vais
pas rêver non heureusement on a on a
quand même des commerçants qui tiennent
le soutiennent qu'ils tiennent bon qu'il
aime bien la barre c'est très compliqué
pour évidemment on a des restaurateurs
qui ont pas ouvert qu'on m'aime pas
voulu faire de vente à emporter un jeu
pour moi je fais plus d'économies
affirmé tout simplement
plutôt que de gérer les stocks qu'ils
étaient les stocks et gérer quand même
ses livraisons qui sont compliqués à
gérer
aujourd'hui on n'a pas eu d' alerte
direct de commerçants qui vont fermer
mais on est vigilant on est très
vigilant parce qu'évidemment les
semaines à venir vont être très
compliqué et le début d'année prochaine
va être compliqué je parlais de ces
sévères qui qui montrent un petit peu au
créneau il y en a cent dix à travers la
france qui ont signé un courrier le 14
novembre dernier c'est l'appel du 14
novembre
certains de ces mères sont des yvelines
que ce soit plaisir chanteloup la
verrière saint cyr et ils demandent
qu'un milliard d'euros sur les 110 du
plan de relance soit consacrée aux
territoires en décrochage quartiers
prioritaires aux villes les plus en
difficulté vous n'avez pas signé cet
appel forcément sollicité non plus mais
est-ce que vous l'approuvez cette
démarche est est ce que cet argent peut
être aussi pour votre commune et
certains quartiers de ce serait
nécessaire j'ai pas été société parce
que pour le coup version là
un peu de chance et même beaucoup de
chance on n'est pas dans des quartiers
prioritaires et des partenaires des
quartiers en difficulté
je soutiens évidemment la démarche il
faut il faut aider on voit le désespoir
qui peut y avoir dans certaines dans
certaines communes dans certains
quartiers il faut aider ces jeunes qui
n'arrivent pas avoir d'emploi en ce
moment parce que c'est très compliqué
qui avaient des jobs étudiants qui ne
peuvent pas les maintenir et donc du
coup sont en difficultés pour se loger
il faut évidemment aidé dans ce plan de
relance pour que ces quartiers puissent
aider à voir des solutions et puissent
vivre vivre vivre une dernière question
sur une autre peut-être plus optimiste
la première réalisation de votre ville
ce sera quoi sous votre début de mandat
première réalisation premier projet et
qui va voir le jour
j'espère très bientôt en tout début
d'année prochaine
réussir à passer aux héros plastique et
aux circuits courts dans la restauration
scolaire et après il ya plein d'autres
jaequi qui vont arriver au cours de
l'année 2021 et notamment les budgets
participatifs
on a été une équipe depuis 2014 de
proximité avec les incisions on va
continuer avec toutes les réunions
publiques
les facebook live et cette continuité
passe aussi par l'interaction continue
avec les artisiens et la mise en place
des nouveaux conseils de quartier et des
budgets participatifs vont dans ses
démarches là et pour mettre encore plus
les artisiens au centre de l'action en
espérant que 2021 soit effectivement une
année un petit peu plus calme
merci je voulais plus d'être revenue sur
sa cave où vous êtes le nouveau maire
donc de bois d'arcy
merci nous poursuivons à cette émission
à présent avec un verdict attendu celui
du tribunal administratif de versailles
saisie par philippe brillault le merdy
viable divers-droite pardon sortant du
chesnay rocancourt depuis 1989 il a été
battu en mars dernier par le candidat
modem richard delpierre l'instance donc
le tribunal administratif vient de se
prononcer l'élection municipale est
annulé en raison de deux irrégularités
un recours devant le conseil d'état est
toujours possible explication réaction
avec eléonore sinoquet le couperet est
tombé
le tribunal administratif de versailles
a décidé d'annuler l'élection municipale
du chéné rocancourt cela fait suite au
recours déposé par l'ancien maire
philippe brillault contre l'actuel
premier édile richard ii le pierre élu
dès le premier tour le 15 mars dernier
avec seulement 76 voix d'avancé pour le
candidat déchu
justice a été rendue est ce que les
élections du mois de mars sont sincères
c'est la question que nous avons posée
au tribunal et nous sommes satisfaits de
sa réponse aujourd'hui le scrutin
n'était pas sincère et donc l'annulation
des élections
c'est ce que nous attendions du côté du
nouveau maire l'inquiétude ne se fait
pas sentir il dit prendre acte du
jugement du tribunal administratif
je peux être satisfait ou insatisfait un
moment voilà ça fait partie du droit
électoral je n'ai pas pour habitude de
commenter les décisions de justice
quelle qu'elle soit donc je resterai
fidèle à mes habitudes et donc nous ne
commenterons pas cette décision de
justice
dans son jugement le tribunal a statué
que des éléments ont pu troubler les
électeurs en cause un sondage envoyé à
des habitants une campagne d'affichage
sauvage ou encore une publication sur
facebook contre fille brio les deux
parties ont désormais un mois pour faire
appel auprès du conseil d'état
on va avec mes colistiers notre avocat
prendre le temps d'examiner le jugement
est de voir la suite que nous souhaitons
donner cette décision de justice est
évidemment va pas faire appel sur une
décision qui est plutôt notre faveur si
jamais un appel est fait cela prolongera
d'un mois la procédure avant que le
conseil d'état ne confirme ou n'infirme
la décision de justice
quoi qu'il en soit la bataille des
municipales aux généraux concours n'est
pas terminée en cas de nouvelles
élections
les deux hommes l'ont déjà annoncé ils
seront tous deux candidats est à noter
que du côté de chevreuse ville ou au là
aussi le scrutin municipal a été annulée
c'est à présent la décision du conseil
d'état qui se fait attendre à néry le
pallec reste donc mer pour le moment une
voix seulement la séparait de son
adversaire
stéphane cattaneo à l'origine du recours
les déclarations des responsables
politiques se sont multipliées ces
dernières semaines à la faveur d'un
report du scrutin régional et
départemental
la date de juin 2021 devrait donc
remplacer celle prévue de mars nicolas
attendri nous explique les raisons et
les enjeux de ce report un report des
élections départementales et régionales
au mois de juin 2021 a été acté c'est la
conclusion du rapport rendu au premier
ministre par jean louis debré l'ancien
président du conseil constitutionnel a
auditionné des représentants politiques
scientifiques et administratifs une
décision qui fait consensus entre dans
la sphère politique
écouter l'un des principaux intéressés
dans le département d
interrogé par nos confrères de radio
sensations depuis plusieurs semaines je
dis à mes collègues présentent conseils
départementaux que le pire serait de
reproduire ce qui s'est passé en mars
dernier pour les élections municipales
car nous perdrions la confiance de nos
concitoyens donc organisons ces
élections étaient fin du printemps pour
la campagne électorale c'est à dire le
mois de mai élections au mois de juin
posons aussi la question de savoir s'il
ne serait pas intelligent de séparer des
élections départementales et régionales
dans ce rapport on retrouve plusieurs
recommandations d'abord le gouvernement
devra fixer et annoncer publiquement la
nouvelle date du scrutin
le parlement devra donc discuter d'un
projet de loi présenté par l'exécutif
les parlementaires pourront débattre à
la fois sur les conditions
d'organisation du scrutin et de la
campagne écoutez à ce propos la
sénatrice des yvelines martha de cidre
est qu il me semble que le point sur
lequel il faut que nous soyons très
attentifs c'est les modalités de la
campagne puisque une campagne en période
de crise sanitaire très clairement ne se
passera pas de la même manière qu'en
temps normal
et pour les candidats il faut qu'ils se
sentent tous dans la capacité de pouvoir
la mener au mieux avec des moyens je
dirais les plus équivalent les plus
équitable possible pour que chacun
puisse se faire entendre
enfin un rapport du conseil scientifique
kobe de 10,9 sur la situation sanitaire
devra être remis à la proche du scrutin
et alors que la date donc des régionales
des départementales restent inconnues
certains se projette encore plus loin
c'est le cas de jean luc mélenchon le
leader de la france insoumise qui a
d'ores et déjà annoncé sa candidature à
la présidentielle de 2000 22 sur le
terrain ses troupes s'organise nous
avons rencontré thibault marshall un
référent dans les yvelines
[Musique]
je la comprends d'autant plus que le
parti de gauche auquel j'appartiens a
demandé lors de son dernier conseil
national à jean luc mélenchon d'être le
candidat de la france ainsi mise pour
2022 donc par ailleurs il avait consulté
l'ensemble des insomnies en vous
envoyant un mail avec un formulaire de
réponse et puis donc c'est quelque chose
qu'on attendait il ya plusieurs raisons
pour ses 18 mois de campagne la première
raison c'est l'objectif de la france est
soumise clairement n'est pas simplement
de rassembler la gauche ou voilà notre
objectif c'est d'aller convaincre les
abstentionnistes convaincre les
abstentionnistes elle ne peut pas se
faire sur une campagne de six mois ça
apprend qu'un temps même 18 mois ces
mêmes sans doute malheureusement trop
or ce que la france a soumis sa et et
l'originalité de ses campagnes
ça a été bien sûr les hologrammes de 17
mais depuis nous avons fait une caravane
des droits sociaux qui s'est arrêtée
dans les épices genre de démarche
d'éducation populaire également d'aller
aider les gens dans leurs quartiers à
s'investir
eh bien nous allons nous continuer
propos recueillis par mélanique poquet
pour refermer ce numéro du 7-8 politique
un mot du vote actuellement en cours
pour désigner le nouveau président du
modem dans les yvelines les adhérents se
prononce donc en ce moment en ligne et
ce jusqu'au 19 novembre ils doivent
départager
tony antonios adhérents de saint rémy
les chevreuse de jean baptiste à monique
nouveau maire de villepreux déjà
porte-parole du mouvement dans les
yvelines rappelons que dans le
département le modem compte deux députés
dont son président sortant bruno myle
yen qui ne se représente donc pas après
deux mandats le 7-8 ce politique revient
bientôt sur tv 78 replays des
différentes éditions sur notre site
internet et applications mobiles d'ici
là l'actualité au quotidien et à suivre
dans le journal du lundi au vendredi à
18h très belle soirée
[Musique]